these four types of competition may seem
like a lot and they can be but you don't
need to focus on all of them at once
it's just really to help you organize
your thoughts now with our flavored
water example if you're a brand manager
of this water bottle you'll need to
analyze all four levels of competition
so you know how to position yourselves
in terms of the brand and in terms of
real placement of this product on store
shelves but as a start-up with an app
it's good to know the different types of
competition you have out there at the
different levels but don't bother over
analyzing the competition at levels that
make less sense for you right now like
the budget level so now that we know the
different types of competition how do we
figure out where we fit among them well
let's talk about that now